but first a hundred people were arrested
during violent clashes between
demonstrators and police in London
yesterday to discuss that and more we
can go to South Wales and we shadow him
Secretary Nick Thomas Simmons thank you
very much for being on the program this
morning how disturbed were you by the
scenes that you saw yesterday I was
extremely disturbed by the scenes
yesterday which were completely and
utterly unacceptable and I want to thank
the Metropolitan Police and all those
frontline officers for the work that
they did yesterday in extremely
difficult circumstances those officers
who were injured I of course wish a
speedy recovery and I want to say a
particular word as well about that all
fall scene if someone urinating next to
PC Keith Palmer's memorial absolutely
despicable behavior and I hope that
individual is identified and brought to
justice
there are reports today that the
government is considering a 10-year jail
sentence for people who desecrate war
memorials I mean do you think there
needs to be some kind of legislative
response to what we see well first year
I would support the government in a
creating a specific offense of
protecting war memorial site and I would
be willing to work with the government
on that but let's not be moved away I
either from what we've seen since the
awful killing of George Floyd in America
because the government needs to show
leadership on the inequality and racism
that still sadly exists in our country
and by that I mean the Prime Minister
the Prime Minister needs to come forward
show that he understands the hurt and
the anguish of the stories that black
people in our country have spoken about
so movingly in recent weeks and also
this set out the concrete steps that his
government now intends to take to
address that well let's talk about
concrete steps shall we because really
in many ways the easy bit is saying that
the government needs to address
inequality what specifically what are
the concrete steps that you
think would make this country more equal
well firstly the government could act on
the recommendations of the Lamy review
which looked at disproportionality in
our criminal justice system and those
recommendations 35 of them have been
there since September 2017 secondly the
government could act on the Wendy
Williams lessons-learned review in two
Windrush which was published in March
again you know 30 recommendations there
to be acted upon and one specifically
Sophie with regard to the Windrush
compensation scheme in its first year of
operation it has only compensated 60
people to a total of 360 thousand pounds
now of course I'm pleased for those 60
people but we're talking about thousands
of people who were wronged over
generations that such a small number has
been compensated only that number is a
chronic failure of political leadership
the government needs to focus it needs
to step up to the plate and it needs to
act what one of the things that many
people feel very strongly about who are
out protesting in recent days and weeks
is the police and the way that the
police treat people of different races
and in 2018 to 19 black people in the UK
9 times more likely to be stopped and
searched by police as white people over
three times as likely to be arrested
they were more than 5 times as likely to
have force used against them by police
do you think there is an issue with the
way that police in the UK deal with
people of different races
well the Lamy review identified issues
right through the system that needed
what do you think what do you think I'm
interested do you think that there is a
racism issue in the police actively well
look we've had great progress since the
McPherson report of 1999 which of course
did identify institutional racism there
has been a lot of progress since then
but there are still disproportionate
outcomes you are absolutely right to
identify that Sophie that's what the the
Lamy review did and the government
should look at the 35 recommendations in
that report but having spoken to senior
police officer
having spoken to police officer
representatives which I do on a regular
basis in this role I know that they are
committed to tackling this as well and
ensuring that there is maximum
transparency and ensuring - that the
work that is required on community
confidence in policing is done and I'm
pleased to share that priority with them
I just want to ask again just because I
understand you know your sort desire to
to look at the lambing report to talk
about recommendations but do you feel
there is an issue with the UK police on
the way that they deal with people
different races do you or not well the
the outcomes of our whole criminal
justice system do suggest there are
issues Sophia where I'm reticent around
answering this of course there will be
things like unconscious bias that we of
course have to deal with where you know
I'm not saying individual police
officers aren't doing their best they of
course are but the way to deal with this
is through professionalism and
transparency and my point is it's not
sort of some sort of situation of people
on the one side police on the other the
police officers I speak to are equally
as committed to tackling this as anyone
else and I think working with the police
going forward is the way to solve this
and to make sure that we do have that
community trust in policing that's so
vital
now you very turd using the black lives
matter hashtag er as has kissed armor
and when you go on the official black
lives matter website one of the first
things you see is a link which says
defund the police elsewhere on the
website it says we call for a national
defunding of police do you agree with
those aims well well no I don't want it
to defund the police but what I do say
Sophie is that there is a very deep
anger out there and it's not for me to
start lecturing people as to how to
express that anger here is where I say
again the government has to step up to
act recognise the depth of feeling
recognise the depth of the anger and the
Prime Minister has to show leadership
acknowledge this anger acknowledge the
structural racism inequality that exists
unless I've indicated already do
something about
don't act that's what we need at this
powerful national moment okay now just
to discuss a couple of other things and
shops are gonna be reopening from
tomorrow
many businesses saying that the 2-meter
social distancing rule is making it very
difficult for them to actually open in a
way that means it will be financially
viable and do you think that t meter
rule should be reduced it should be
reduced if the evidence indicated that
it should be and this is where we need
to be so careful Sophie because the
public health position and the health of
the economy go together there's no point
seeing them in conflicts if the
government did ease lockdown too quickly
if it did move to one meter without
there being scientific advice backing
that you would end up with a second peep
which would cause even greater economic
damage so my message to the government
is to be vigilant be cautious approach
this in a structured way and publish the
evidence so we can all see it we can get
that restoration of confidence in the
public health advice which the Dominic
Cummings affair did so much damage to
although really we do know some of the
scientific advice date we I mean we
understand that there is obviously a
risk at one meter
a reduced risk at two meters it's a
political decision isn't it you can't
just always follow the science well it's
a political decision it should be based
on a range of scientific advice Sophie
but if that range of scientific advice
was published then that would restore
confidence in the decisions that the
government is making and it would also
as I say give that transparency that we
require so that we can all judge the
decisions see that they're being making
in an open way everybody can have
confidence in that going forward now the
Sunday Times is reporting that plans to
allow people to change their legal
gender without a medical diagnosis and
self-identify as a different sex have
been scrapped by the government is that
the right decision well what I think we
need to look at in this space is what
trans people actually
think and say to us now I think trans
rights are human rights I've said that
before and I think we need to listen
very carefully going forward in what is
an extremely sensitive area I'm not sure
the government just scrapping plans and
then leaking it out in a newspaper is
the way to deal with this I think we
need a much better way going forward
that sensitive that seeks consensus and
respects everybody's rights now we are
at a time but I do just want to squeeze
and one more question if possible and
we've seen a pretty extraordinary
turnaround in Labour's polling and one
poll this week saying you're just five
points behind the Conservatives the
context the gap was 22 points in
mid-march
Kirstin with the highest ratings of any
opposition leader since tony blair does
that make you think maybe jeremy corbyn
was the problem all along it just makes
it makes me think about the present
Sophie not the past I think what it what
what we're seeing is a vindication here
at the approach that kia stahma is
taking as leader of the Labour Party but
the reality is that at the moment party
politics is not a priority the priority
at the moment is the constructive
opposition and the approach we are
taking with the government to tackle
coronavirus and to attempt to minimize
loss of life that's the priority at the
moment and party politics I think in E's
normal sense can wait for the future
once we're through what is this
extraordinarily challenging global
pandemic very diplomatic
thank you very much having on the
program thank you